let's jump to the story from forbes
though this is interesting california
expected to ban new gas only car sales
by 2035 terrible headline forbes what's
actually happening is as of i think
today they have implemented the first
steps towards banning gas vehicles
vehicles will have to be
zero emission i'm curious what do you
think this is all about james is this is
this climate change and we're trying to
be better stewards of the earth or is
this some kind of communist conspiracy
all right there's an easy litmus test to
find out if we're being better stewards
of the earth
there's a very easy test are those cars
going to be powered by electricity
generated by nuclear power or not no
because if the answer is no we're not
being better stewards of the earth this
is something else but it does mean they
have easier control of your vehicle
that's right those co those vehicles are
um
in all the cases that i'm aware of
electric vehicles are remote
controllable or they can be tough oh
yeah oh dude so we we uh i got a tesla
and there's like a puddle of water and
you stand back and on your phone you can
remote control the car with your phone
and so i'm pressing the button in the
car is backing away from the the swampy
muck and then i can get in it's amazing
yeah that doesn't mean someone else can
do it yeah it totally does mean somebody
else can do it and it probably means
that you know if he so felt like it elon
musk could probably do it he literally
could just
do it which means that if you know
whatever manufacturer maybe elon is and
maybe isn't gets in cahoots with our fbi
that's acting so well then you could get
in your car and it could just drive you
right down to the field office or into
the ocean or into a tree maybe maybe
maybe you'll get in your car and then
it'll start speeding out of control
without your control 90 miles an hour
down wilshire boulevard slam into a tree
because you're a journalist working on a
story about uh a general exactly yeah
exactly i just think it's it's a funny
image of elon musk like sitting in a
room and then he walks up to a guy with
his hands on his shoulder and goes
execute order
69 and then the guy's like okay and then
you press the button all the cars turn
on and start driving to tesla hq it
would actually be that that would be it
would either be that or it would be 420
690 i'm going to say oh
it'd be like execute order 420.69
[Music]
and then the guy's like yeah yeah yeah
okay
yeah so um that reference i made earlier
just a moment ago was actually it's a
real reference michael eisen was a
journalist
he complained to a neighbor that he saw
someone messing with his car asked to
borrow theirs they said no he got in his
car
car speeding down wilshire boulevard
slams into a tree explodes he dies
that's right that's right and he was
working on a story i think it was about
was it about hayden
oh i'm not sure i gotta look that up now
yeah you want to google that real quick
yeah i remember that actually that's
right
that wasn't an electric car though was
it nope nope but but uh for the past i
think you know 15 or so years cars have
been remote controllable there's what
people don't understand cars that were
not designed to be remote controlled can
be remote controlled so these car
hackers
i i watched this thing you know we all
knew that self-driving cars were coming
these car hackers took over a car that
did not have any remote control or
self-driving capabilities because power
steering
can be manipulated by the computer
inside the car
michael hastings was investigating cia
director john brennan brennan okay there
you go
and then his car went out of control on
wilshire and hit a tree and exploded at
a high rate of speed he thought someone
was trying to kill him it was like 11 it
was like 1am he left i think he left the
bar and he was driving home and then
just so he could have been hammered but
you know he's also investigating the
head of the cia i mean and plausible
deniability is all of a thing isn't it
yep yeah no i mean so this though i mean
this is absolute uh
control over over over the population
your control of your movement if you're
stuck with electric vehicles and
and all of this i am proud that i still
drive a car that has like i mean it does
have power steering but it's it has old
school like it has a key there's no
button nice you actually have to use it
it doesn't even have like a key that
folds or whatever it's like a normal key
from the back in the back in the old old
days mechanical locks or are they
automatic they're automatic though
that's what you've got to do but it's a
standard it's a stick shift too if
you're driving
yeah if you're prepping you want a
manual yep like 1960s car
no computer components in it at all
that's what yeah automatic transmissions
hard to fix if if you know if everything
fell apart you'd be better off with man
you will learn how to drive stick
driving stick is fun you know it depends
on
if i'm going to you know what i don't
like i don't like driving stick when i'm
just trying to relax it's like you're
making driving a chore you know what i
mean i don't like driving sticking on
hilly roads like in san francisco
because when i want to but it's like i
want to shift into first gear on a hill
i start to roll backwards so i'm like i
hope someone's giving me 10 feet right
now because they don't yeah i'm in east
tennessee i'm all over hill so they
don't
they never got about four feet so it's
like really a rat like
i'm hitting the clutch to the gas but
putting it jerking forward it's the most
annoying thing i'm sure it's happened to
anybody who's driven stick that you're
on a slight hill and then someone gets
right up on you yeah and then you're
like dude i can't release the break
right now and so you just sit there and
they're honking at you and you're like
you're going to back up i'm going to
stick this i'm going to roll backwards
yeah like that scene at indiana jones i
was like first you throw me the whip
i can't i'm stuck yeah
so the thing about this is a lot of
people are pointing out the green
movement stuff is just about saving the
auto industry that the auto industry is
such a big component of um
the us economy yeah there's i was
reading that like most millionaires in
the u.s are people who own local
dealerships
so yeah yeah
so i mean this is huge so what do you do
got to make new cars but if people have
cars not going to buy a new car why
what's the features not good enough
now you got to make them do it
california is just pumping their economy
i just tweeted out a thing about sweden
that is building a road that recharges
electrical veal vehicles as they drive
over them yeah yeah i was worried about
that um that seems real well it could i
mean it's uh but you're talking about
very powerful electromagnets in the in
the in the you know third rail don't
walk on it i mean what would that be
like so i mean we have wireless charging
for our phones you know you'd probably
be all right to walk on it but a massive
one are your keys going to get like
sucked up or something
i think i just won't walk on that road
it doesn't seem like it's worth the risk
didn't somebody build that solar solar
uh panel road
yeah yeah i heard about that it was like
it's a terrible idea that makes no sense
but they did it because people are are
just the status of solar roads now solar
road really solar roadways was the
company that pioneered it or it was one
of the most popular they made a youtube
video that made no sense yeah it got
really good
well it's like it's funny because
they're like we should make our road
solar panels it's like why because the
roads are exposed to sunlight it's like
okay why don't you just put the solar
panels
next to the roads on stands where
they're not being run over by cars we'll
make them more durable right the
material won't be won't have enough uh
will be too opaque and so it will not
absorb enough sunlight and then they get
damaged and scratched and it refracts
light and then snow gets on it just make
solar panels that can move back and
forth and they're next to the road
you'll save money or build a nuclear
plant there you go yeah that too why why
don't they want to build nuclear plants
well
because it's the way out of managed
energy scarcity because
there's
well fusion would be would be wonderful
but uh
the claim is that the waste can't be
managed or can't be managed safely or
it's politically infeasible but that's
not true not true for fusion especially
it's certainly not true for fusion there
is no i mean the waste the the material
inside the reactor
becomes radioactive uh but
none of that there is no waste it's it's
literally water that comes out of it
and no helium that comes out of it sorry
uh it makes helium it makes healing
hydrogen which by the way helium is a
limited resource this is amazing
it's a win-win big time uh
but it's also a not
real right now thing
but nuclear is the way out of the
like if we if we see this as an energy
transition period to where you know well
maybe we're moving away from from
you know fossil fuels when we have to go
into something different and it's more
green or whatever
it makes every bit of sense to use
nuclear so the the best answer that i
have is that it is the way out of them
being able to manage the energy economy
the way that they want to manage it and
i mean there are some difficulties with
nuclear but they're not
they're not
like death blows or whatever yeah you
can't turn them on and off quickly you
can't ramp up production or ramp down
production quickly in cycle so there are
some limitations but you need like one
gas plant to be able to like adjust for
that yeah and main baseline load can be
covered by nuclear so it's like the
escape hatch isn't there so this is why
i use it as a litmus test
is if they're serious about it being
about
carbon in the atmosphere then they're
they must be pro-nuclear but they're
very anti-nuclear and when you read the
explanations for their anti-nuclear none
of them make sense which means that
something else is going on they're also
buying beachfront property something's
really up because they were talking a
lot about carbon footprint and reducing
carbon emissions and also and i'm like
well actually we can pull the carbon out
of the atmosphere deposited onto
palladium copper gold turned into
graphene there's other ways of turning
it into graphene the carbon dioxide you
can actually mine the carbon dioxide out
of the air and the methane as well you
take the methane out turn it into carbon
dioxide and then turn it into yeah
there's i mean i got all index carbon
capture back like 10 years ago i was
really really into it really interesting
now the world economic forum is talking
about nitrogen foot the nitrogen
footprints too much or it's these f the
dutch farmers i think they're trying to
shut down us because of the nitrogen
football it turns out that there is a
precedent to that that's very
interesting and we're going to go back
into the conspiracy rabbit hole because
there was a book in 1972 published by
the club of rome called the limits to
growth that is a malthusian book it
believes that human populations in
excess of what the earth can actually
support and it's only a matter of time
till everything collapses they predicted
we run out of copper in 2000 by the way
so they weren't that good with their
computer models that they did in the
late 60s and early 70s but in that book
it actually talks about a that we have
to control the fertility rate so that we
don't have too many people but b that
one of the easiest ways to do is control
the food supply because there's not
enough food then there won't be as many
people because people won't make babies
when there's not enough food to feed
them and so then what you can actually
need to control is the levels of
nitrogen fertilizer it's explicitly
written in that book now you think well
what's the connection to this well in
1972 this book comes out so what right
in 1973 klaus schwab invites them to
speak in the third annual world economic
forum meeting
at davos which one was called the
european management forum before it was
called the world economic forum 1974
they brought in a
brazilian communist priest dom elder
kamara is this guy's name or chimera or
camera or something like this i don't
know how to pronounce words in
portuguese but it's spelled c-a-m-r-a
helder camara was the
mentor
spiritual mentor to klaus schwabe said
after he met him and he was known as the
red bishop he was a communist
but he was also the mentor to paulo
ferrari who is the brazilian marxist
educator and it turns out also to
bergoglio who became pope francis
so it's kind of an interesting set of
people that are all involved but camaro
spoke in in 1974 the club of rome spoke
in 1973 and you see this kind of mixture
of this kind of it turns out marx hated
thomas malthus and his ideas but you see
this kind of mixture of marxism and and
and
malthusian ideas kind of percolating
through the world economic forum but
nitrogen fertilizer and the
the buzz word of the book is
sustainability by the way uh nitrogen
fertilizer in the need for a sustainable
world population is the thesis of that
uh part of the book about farming and so
i think that this nitrogen thing is
um has probably other
agendas behind it of course it can you
also what which one was it was it stalin
or was it london that said if you
control the food you control the people
sounds like something stalin would say i
think that was stalin that said that and
so
i i don't know if lenin was as murderous
i think you know do you think stalin
killed london
i have no idea i think he poisoned him i
have no idea i do know though that if i
were like really bad people that operate
in this really bad people space
not saying that that's what's actually
occurring but i would possibly consider
manufacturing a famine and then offer
digital ration cards that get you on
your digital
currency to buy food and then you would
say that people like preppers who stored
food and became self-sufficient are
people who hoarded food and that they're
the cause of the food crisis
and that you're going to have a uh what
was klaus's quote prepare for an angrier
world and you're going to have a very
angry world at that point you guys were
close it wasn't stalin that said if you
control the food you control a nation it
wasn't lenin it was henry kissinger oh
guess who's the great architect of the
west and also literally also literally
the mentor of klaus schwab wow literally
he's looked that up it's clash royale
mentors
must be working together to transition
from the liberal economic order to a new
world order they must be and that's the
connection i've needed between the world
economic forum the united states it's
kissinger and klaus schwab look them up
and they're they're they're like two
peas in a pod um and it turns out that
uh china is the model the chinese system
with its surveillance the social credit
et cetera is a social control model for
the world uh that's the practice run
which by the way right now seems to be
although it's hard to say because you
don't know what's true coming out of
their cracking a bit people are not
happy in in the chinese system right now
so scary stuff there he also says if you
control the energy you control a region
i believe this is all part of the thing
if you control the food you control a
nation it's funny that we thought it was
stalin and it's kissinger if you control
the money you control the world
these guys why what's kissinger's deal
was he like
an america was he in the liberal like
the john locke libert i don't think so
my guess is that he is what you would
call an old hegelian so hegel's cult of
of uh science or whatever you want to
call it of alchemy split into two groups
immediately following his death in 1831
there were the young hegelians and marx
was a young hegelian and
then there were the old hegelians and uh
they were kind of competing they were
basically the liberal and conservative
versions and so what the young hegelians
believe just look at marks and you can
figure it out what the old hegelians
believed is actually that the ideal
system had been arrived at in 1830s
prussia believe it or not that's what
they believed and that the goal was to
use the dialectical powers or method
that hagel had put forth to spread it
around the world which is what we would
call nation building if we were to say
neocons today so my suspicion is that
the neocons why are the rhinos so much
like the democrats is because they're
actually both hegelian in their
orientation you have the the old ones
who believe that i don't know it's the
end of history and the last man was the
title of the 1989 book by francis
fukuyama that you're then going to
spread democracy of the american style
around the globe you're going to do
nation building and color revolutions
and take over one nation after another
in order to get there and then on the
other hand you have the marxists
competing with them as two sides of the
same the same program what is dialectic
you've mentioned that a couple times you
said the dialectic nature what is that
the dialectic is a combination of
opposites to lift up to a higher level
of understanding so they'll they'll
intentionally create an opposition in
order to get something to the next level
correct they call it sublation in
marxism thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you